bonjour à tous bienvenue dans europe et
donc votre rendez vous de l'actualité
européenne des chaînes parlementaires
dans cette émission je vous emmène en
roumanie avec près de 15 millions
d'hectares de terres ce pays dispose de
la cinquième plus grande surface
agricole de l'union européenne est une
aubaine pour de nombreux agriculteurs et
investisseurs étrangers qui achètent des
terres arables alors faut-il se méfier
de la ruée vers les terres roumaines
nous en débattrons avec nos invités mais
d'abord l'actualité depuis quelques mois
les couloirs de bruxelles et de navarre
bruisse de rumeurs sur le futur traité
transatlantique dont les négociations se
déroulent à huis clos alors ce tt ip et
ils antidémocratique c'est la question
de la semaine avec simon barbarie
celles traitées qui fait peur le tt ip
le partenariat transatlantique de
commerce et d'investissement prévue pour
entrer en vigueur dès l'année prochaine
cet accord mettrait en place une
gigantesque zone de libre échange entre
les états unis et l'europe un marché de
820 millions de consommateurs ça en fait
du monde une véritable arme secrète pour
les états en maille de reprise
économique non mais alors pourquoi les
négociations entre la commission et
washington sont elles si discrète rien
ne filtre y compris pour les députés
européens pourtant représentants du
peuple
pour les opposants au traité les
négociations seraient carrément
illégitime avec le ppip les
réglementations entre l'amérique et le
vieux continent seraient harmonisés mais
par le bas on pourrait par exemple voir
débarquer en europe un bon gros boeuf
aux hormones américain pire en cas de
différend entre une entreprise et un
état c'est une durée diction privé qui
devra trancher par exemple si une
réglementation nationale dérange
multinationales la france pourrait se
voir condamner comme un vulgaire
justiciables il faudra y réfléchir à
deux fois quand on votera une loi alors
le tti paie un accord anti démocratique
alors ce traité transatlantique est il
véritablement antidémocratique ce karim
zéribi que je reçois pour en parler
bonjour bonjour vous êtes député
européen membre du groupe des verts et
vous êtes membre de la délégation avec
les états unis et la commission des
affaires étrangères alors anti
démocratique ou pas très dangereux en
tout cas pour l'europe ce traité de
libre échange que nous combattons nous
écologistes au parlement européen nous
avons fait partie des députés qui ont
voté contre l'ouverture des négociations
négociations qui ont commencé en juin
2013 avec un mandat donné à la
commission mais dont on ne sait plus
grand chose aujourd'hui à dire vrai et
pour nous ça représente un danger sur
des enjeux environnementaux d'abord en
tant qu'écologiste aussi alimentaires
agricoles les normes les standards
sociaux et environnementaux européens
vont exploser pour se mettre au niveau
des européens on ne veut pas d'une
europe américanisé pour nous écologique
on vous dit que rien ne filtre il ya
pourtant huit députés qui sont censés
être associé en fait à cette négociation
vous ne discutait pas finalement avec
vos homologues nous discutons avec les
membres du congrès j'ai moi même été à
dublin puis à washington mais la
discussion ne contient pas des éléments
de fond est d'accord qui sont
susceptibles d'être aujourd'hui passé
entre la commission et le commissaire
concerné par ces affaires car le groupe
est sûrement le qu'américains à un
moment donné on va nous proposer de
qu'un accord de libre-échange ficelé
qu'il faudra effectivement validé au
parlement européen j'espère que le
parlera le parlement mettra son veto car
depuis le traité de lisbonne tout accord
de libre échange doit être validé par le
parlement européen et les parlementaires
heureusement la particularité c'est que
ce soit voulu valider en paquet soit
vous le valider en l'état soit vous le
il faut le refuser le refuser cet accord
de libre échange je pense effectivement
qui nous tire vers le bas qui rompt pas
d'antenne danger votre reportage est
très bande de ce point de vue les ogm le
poulet javellisée deux clubs boeuf aux
hormones tout ce qui faisait les normes
l'exigence environnementale de synthés
alimentaire européenne va exploser pour
se mettre au niveau des amériques et
nous non vous le connaissez le mandat de
karel de gucht le commissaire européen a
obtenu ce mandat de la part du conseil
c'est à dire les états membres vous
savez ce qu'il ya dans ce
dans ce mandat mais très floue son
mandat il est très opaque on sait
effectivement qu'il y a quelques
éléments que nous avons souhaité au
telle exception culturelle de la france
s'est beaucoup battue elle nécessite
effectivement une bataille nécessite une
bataille de conseils mais tout ce qui
n'apparaît pas dans les éléments de
négociation peuvent être discutés par
ailleurs donc par le commissaire en
question n'ont très franchement on ouvre
une boîte de pandore qui met en danger à
la fois les citoyens les consommateurs
européens sous prétexte qu'on gagnerait
quelques centièmes de points alors
justement on nous annonce en fait des
créations d'emplois de la croissance on
en a peut-être besoin au moment où la
zone euro et a fortiori l'europe entière
à une croissance atone on a besoin d'une
développement on a besoin de sortir de
l'austérité on a douzaine de renforcer
d'autres qui cherchent une solution un
marché de libre échange si je puis dire
avec 800 réponses à nos problématiques
d'emploi de chômage d'inquiétude de nos
colonnes la création d'un livre échange
avec je ne le crois pas marcher de 820
millions à l'heure où on à la chine d'un
côté l'un d'un milliard et demi un
milliard de l'autre côté pour que
l'enjeu aujourd'hui c'est de renforcer
un tissu économique qui s'appelle les
pme les pmi c'est d'aller dans un champ
de l'innovation c'est d'aller vers
l'économie verte d'aller vers l'exigence
environnementale
là effectivement nous avons des pistes
et des gisements d'emplois considérables
pour l'europe sans pour autant brader
tout ce à quoi nous tenons et nous avons
aujourd'hui fait monter en puissance des
standards sociaux environnementaux il ne
faut pas qu'ils explosent sous l'égide
de ce traité de libre échange il ya un
véritable danger aujourd'hui il faut
comprendre la considération et à mesure
alors il ya un autre projet qui inquiète
nos concitoyens c'est cette histoire de
justice arbitrale ça veut dire que en
gros dans ce traité enfin tout ça ce
sont des supputations sait que rien
n'est acté aujourd'hui à l'heure où l'on
parle la justice ne serait pas rendue
par une juridiction
qui seraient des juges mais par une
forme de justice arbitrale qui mettrait
les états au même titre que les
multinationales donc on pourrait
attaquer les états au même titre qu'une
multinationale donc demain si exxon
mobil attaque par exemple la pologne en
disant nous on veut exploiter le gaz de
schiste vous pourriez être condamné
c'est un traité qui va favoriser les
multinationales et leur puissance est
aussi effectivement où ça va nous mener
vous parlez d'énergie le gaz de schiste
notamment ce traité permettra aux
multinationales d'aller au delà des
législations nationales et listes
nationales qui ont été lus par la
souveraineté nationale par les peuples
va être mise à mal donc c'est un traité
qui va nous mener sur le chemin qui va
être celui je dirais de la mise à mal de
la démocratie à laquelle nous tenons de
traité antidémocratique traité qui
favorise les multinationales traité qui
va favoriser le business on me dira
saint standards environnementaux et
sociaux aujourd'hui et malouda ceux ci
ce sont ces schistes permettra à une
multinationale de venir je dirais faire
des forages and europe alors que nous
avons en gros vous êtes en train de dire
s'il sonne mobile pourrait par exemple
devenir fort et en ile-de-france et juan
nous on a obtenu le droit par cette
justice arbitrale sous l'égide de ce
traité on pourra mettre la france en
difficulté si celle ci le refuse
effectivement d'ouvrir je dirais du
foncier du terrain disponible pour de la
halle à l'exploitation du gaz de schiste
et nous considérons nous encore une fois
qu'ils seront pleines la nage est
considérable donc il faut aujourd'hui
que nous puissions tirer l'europe vers
le haut nos collections vers l'eau que
l'europe soit un exemple qu'il y ait un
modèle européen
c'est ça le vrai défi qui se présente à
nous servir de s'américaniser vous nous
parler de modèle européen c'est assez
drôle si je puis dire sachant qu'on
vient de sortir des municipales
actuellement en france vous êtes de
marseille karim zéribi et vous avez
depuis quelques jours un nouveau maire
dans le 7e secteur et je voudrais qu'on
écoute
en gagnant ici eh bien nous pouvons
gagner la france donc c'est une étape
qui doit nous conduire à terme à
2017 le rendez vous encore plus
historique que celui que nous venons de
prouver si localement c'est 2017 et
voilà c'est une une première marche ou
une étape vers cet vers cet objectif
karim zéribi la prochaine étape 2010 est
entre temps on a les européennes qu'est
ce qu'on peut faire pour contrer le fn
dans une ville comme marseille il faut
pas le diaboliser il faut débattre avec
lui sur le fond et il faut effectuer en
prendre en considération la désespérance
de nos concitoyens et puis ce qui
favorise le front national c'est
l'abstention lorsque l'abstention est
forte mécaniquement le front national
est aussi de qu'il faut faire en sorte
de recoller renouer la confiance entre
nos concitoyens le politique on étend d
affection forte moi j'ai fait campagne à
marseille pour les municipales les
marseillais et les français en général
n'y croit plus et donc ceux qui se
déplacent vers les urnes ont envie de
sanctionner de protester je dirais
d'exhorter un mal être il faut apporter
des réponses fortes est pour moi ces
réponses le sont républicaines sont
aussi dans l'innovation on ne peut plus
faire de la politique comme les partis
traditionnels nous propose de le faire
de qu'il faut ouvrir une nouvelle ère et
le front national apparaît aujourd'hui
c'était c'est un comble comme le parti
j'ai envie de dire un peu décomplexée de
la rénovation c'est catastrophique
d'imaginer ça mais quand on voit des
maires au front national compte 30 ans
35 ans et quand on voit effectivement
des gens s'accrocher à leur mandat 70 75
ans à l'ump ou au ps ait pas
effectivement qu'il faut s'interroger
sur le renouvellement du personnel
politique sur une authenticité retrouver
en politique sur un discours vrai et
puis surtout sur des réponses qui sont
de réponse républicaine laïque forte où
tout un chacun pourra se retrouver le
front national c'est la division c'est
le rejet c'est la n2 on le sait
maintenant il faut l'attaquer sur le
fond quel projet gravier et moi nous
montrer ce qui va être capable de faire
à l'envers la mairie du 7e secteur
karim zéribi
on annonce 23% potentiellement dans les
sondages pour le camp de marine le pen
lors des prochaines européennes
comment on fait quand un parlement
européen peut-être d'ici juillet aura un
groupe politique qui représentera
peut-être 25% d'abord d'ici là faut
faire campagne et
européen convaincu comme nos écologistes
il faut indiquer que ne sommes pas des
européens nous voulons réorienter
l'europe la réajuster changer l'europe
mais changer l'europe et du fédéralisme
ce que les membres changer l'europe pour
faire en sorte que l'europe a encore une
fois soit une europe n'ont pas de
l'austérité mais des investissements
d'avenir de la jeunesse de l'emploi de
la solidarité de septembre au plat est
apparu très libérale de que plutôt
favorable aux multinationales aux grands
acteurs économiques à la finance est
effectué en tant qu'on aura cet finir
avec leur démarche et tant qu'on aura
cette europe là nos concitoyens il n'y
croiront pas et voudront et auront la
tentation du repli de l'euro c'est ici
me qui est porté par le front national
dont il faut faire campagne pour une
europe du changement une réorientation
de donner vie à l'europe en indiquait
effectivement il ya des combats à mener
et puis effectivement ensuite il va
falloir batailler au sein du parlement
européen parce que si on a des
eurosceptiques le chemin pour faire
avancer l'europe va être plus difficile
il faut que nos concitoyens l'entendent
il faut mettre je crois en place
parlement européen des eurodéputés de
combat favorable à une nouvelle
solidarité c'est effectivement moi la
mode en ce moment merci beaucoup car
elle est ravie d'avoir été avec nous
nous on continue direction la roumanie
peut-être le futur grenier de l'europe
ce qui l'a été dans l'entre-deux-guerres
depuis quelques années de nombreux
investisseurs et agriculteurs achètent
des terres arables là-bas pour investir
un véritable eldorado mais certains y
voient déjà un accaparement des terres
décryptage par marie brévaux et mehdi
chebana
dans la famille de denis thomas on est
viticulteur de père en fils depuis plus
de dix générations en plein coeur de la
bourgogne à nuits saint georges
alors je vous emmène dans l'ignoble donc
sur les coteaux et
quatre cinquièmes de nos vignes
quand en 1995 le domaine familial est
vendu ce passionné sa femme font leurs
valises direction ça athènes un petit
village à 150 km de bucarest
je suis venu en roumanie
attiré par le pinot noir
bon étant bourguignon c'est mon cépages
de prédilection et je cherchais pour
l'entreprise familiale que je dirigeais
à développer les pinots noirs de qualité
ni
l'orientation l'amplitude thermique des
terrains calcaires et haïr et toutes les
conditions ici sont réunis pour un
terroir d'exception mais si denis thomas
s'est exilé c'est surtout qu'en roumanie
les terres agricoles représentent encore
de belles opportunités
l'hectare ici est 20 fois moins cher que
dans sa région natale
mai 2000 euros lecteurs pour des la
terre non plantés et
5000 pour des vignes plantées en bon
état 5 à 10 milles pour des vignes
plantées en vo nets gains en bourgogne
c'est on commence à 60 milles pour finir
à 1 million d'hectares
le français est désormais à la tête d'un
domaine viticole de 70 hectares le fruit
de 15 en investissement si denis doit
faire face à beaucoup de tracasseries
administratives
l'accueil des roumains a conforté dans
sa nouvelle vie dix salariés travaillent
à plein temps sur le domaine
bonjour bonjour tout mon respect qu'est
ce que vous faites on laboure la saison
a commencé
ici le regard porté sur les
propriétaires terriens étrangers et
bienveillant et surtout pragmatique
c'est une bonne chose qu'il vienne ici
et qu'ils fassent des affaires plutôt
que ça reste en l'état c'est une bonne
chose j'ai un avis plutôt positif
s'il n'était pas venu peut-être qu'on ne
travaillerait plus
être propriétaire c'est un rêve moi j'ai
une propriété j'ai un hectare de vigne
c'est suffisant
pour nicolas et exploiter la terre pour
son propre compte et une lointaine
chimère comme pour beaucoup de paysans
room 70% des terres reste consacré à une
agriculture de subsistance une
agriculture familiale
à la mairie de sare athènes la ruée des
fermes les occidentaux est perçu comme
une opportunité
l'occasion de moderniser une agriculture
souvent archaïques dans la région 30 %
des exploitations agricoles sont détenus
par des européens
contre à 28 ans votre adresse on apprend
beaucoup auprès des étrangers une
association avec les étrangers a
toujours apporté de bonnes choses
en fait il ne travaille pas vraiment ils
ont apporté les machines les outils et
ce sont les habitants de la commune et
de la région qui travaillent pour eux
physique limité
il n'y a aucun chiffre officiel mais on
estime que 10 % des terres arables en
roumanie seraient détenus par des
étrangers principalement des européens
depuis quelques années des voix
s'élèvent et dénonce un accaparement du
sol roumain avec l'entrée du pays dans
l'union européenne et la libéralisation
du marché foncier il est bien plus
facile d'acheter des terres agricoles
pour les investisseurs étrangers
pour l'une des plus importantes
fédérations de syndicats agricoles le
problème est ailleurs
il faut que je travaille sur ce dossier
des collègues en ont besoin il faut que
je passe les voir
la taille des exploitations pour la
plupart des mini parcelle distribué à la
révolution roumaine ne sont pas à la
hauteur du marché européen
la seule solution c'est l'association le
remembrement c'est la seule solution qui
permettrait de sortir du marasme
car s'associer ça donne la possibilité
de mieux capitaliser les subventions la
possibilité de courir le crédit de la
banque car la surface est plus grande
mais s'associer c'est surtout la
possibilité de vendre la production à un
prix bien plus avantageux
la puissance de négociation des paysans
grandi
depuis 2007 bruxelles a accordé près de
10 milliards d'euros à la roumanie
exclusivement pour l'agriculture et le
développement rural
67 % de cette somme a déjà été utilisé
mais les petits paysans et les petites
exploitations roumaines ont toujours de
très grandes difficultés à accéder à
cfoot
alors la roumanie deviendra-t-elle la
troisième puissance agricole d'europe je
reçois des députés européens sur ce
plateau pour en parler cristian dan
preda bonjour vous êtes député européen
orge roumain membre du parti populaire
européen et marc tarabella on ne vous
présente plus vous êtes député belge
socialistes et démocrates cristian dan
preda je me tourne vers vous il y a
énormément de polémique autour de cette
question d'achat de terres arables par
des européens de l'ouest voire par des
étrangers extra-européens
est-ce que vous parlez ici
d'accaparement de terres arables ou est
ce que c'est une opportunité pour la
roumanie non c'est une excellente
opportunité donc nos frères européens
ont déjà profité il faut dire que
quelques 800 mille hectares sur les
14,7 millions de hectares
terres arables je veux dire sont déjà
détenues par des italiens des allemands
des anglais des espagnols
les suisses si ils sont là il ya aussi
quelques 10 % de ses tanins qui sont
détenus par des gens venant des pays
arabes et cela était possible même avant
cette libéralisation complète de 1er
janvier 2014 parce qu'il ya eu des
achats par des sociétés et donc comme
dans votre reportage dans le domaine du
vignoble dans différentes cultures
agricoles
on en a profité c'est pour le bien du
pays cet excellent et ça doit continuer
vous êtes d'accord marc tarabella et ce
n'est pas une part en fait de
privatisation six étudiants des terres
arables roumaine je suis partiellement
d'accord et qui vient dire c'est vrai
que l'agriculture roumaine à vocation et
la roumanie à vocation devenir un des
plus grands producteurs agricoles
européens il est exceptionnel l'europe
dans l'entre-deux-guerres et l'idée
c'est d'y revenir il ya beaucoup de
terre de qualité un climat exceptionnel
et qui sont sous-exploitées c'est vrai
mais la plus grande partie de la
population rurale vit de l'agriculture
alors c'est vrai que c'est une
agriculture de subsistance
qui permet quand même aux gens de se
nourrir alors c'est vrai qu'ils vivent
dans des conditions précaires très
souvent et qu'on a envie d'un
développement ma crainte à moi je le dis
clairement c'est que la transition
agricole qu'on a vécu au niveau de
différents pays européens comme la
france la belgique ou aujourd'hui on est
à 1 ou 2 ou 3% de la population active
qui vit de l'agriculture par rapport à
30 ou 40 %
pour les romains oui mais nous avions
nous avons vécu ça aussi dans l'avant
guerre chez nous la même proportion de
population et être impliqué dans
l'agriculture pour régner une femme j'en
ai transition industrielle qui rend this
y ont beaucoup trop rapide et qu'il va
devenir à vos pulsations rural ici le
viticulteur à 70 hectares il fait
travailler dix personnes
j'ai vu des fermes en roumanie 2-3 4000
hectares qui fonctionne avec cinq six
tracteurs donc cinq six emplois temps
plein et donc je me dis que s'il ya un
accaparement des terres c'est quand même
au détriment de petites surfaces
d'agriculteurs qui aujourd'hui
produisent pour se nourrir et c'est vrai
ne développe pas malheureusement
l'activité économique qu'ils
mériteraient de développer mais si on va
d'une transition d'une petite
agriculture de subsistance directement
vers une agriculture hyper productiviste
il y aura peut-être que certaines zones
montagneuses où les petits agriculteurs
vont pouvoir se maintenir voire
développer leurs activités car ils le
mériteraient de commercialiser leurs
produits et on parle directement ici du
marché européen
attention il ya aussi la demande
intérieure et je crois que la
souveraineté alimentaire c'est aussi
quelque chose d'important et donc ma
crainte c'est que va devenir l'essentiel
de la paysannerie roumaine dans les
années à venir sachant que les terres
vont être effectivement prise est
accaparé par des fermes de plus en plus
grosse et qui vont être porteuse de
moins en moins d'emplois est la presse
elle même justement est ce qu'il faut
craindre une forme de transition trop
rapide vers une agriculture je dirais de
marché qui derrière va coûter aussi de
l'emploi non je crois que achement là il
ya un certain équilibre entre
les petites exploitations et les grandes
rit encore presque 40% des gens qui
vivent de l'agriculture et pour le
paysan roumain s'est quand même vu le
niveau moyen de vie une chance ordinaire
il faut savoir que la subvention payer
pour un hectare en roumanie 7 au niveau
de l'année 2013
dans les quelque 140 euros et ça va
augmenter jusqu'en 2019 jusqu'à 190 oui
mais ces exemples sicile il s'agit en
fait de donner ces subventions si je
puis dire à des étrangers pour exploiter
les terres roumaines est-ce qu'il ya pas
un hiatus là non parce que quand je
disais il n'y a pas
dans l'est dans les années qui nous ont
précédés et si c'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui je vais en devenir il n'y a
pas un accaparement comme vous avez dit
on a beaucoup discuté juste avant le 1er
janvier ce moment 2014 ce moment de
libéralisation complète danger comme
quoi il y aura une sorte d' invasion oui
j'ai d'ailleurs été à monsieur manipulés
par des mouvements nationalistes en
voilà et c'est pas le cas on est en
avril et le pli n'a pas bougé par
rapport à l'automne passé il n'y a pas
eu des ventes
exceptionnelles
au contraire il ya une sorte de gel
maintenant parce que beaucoup de gens ne
veulent pas vendre parce qu'ils
attendent depuis plus élevés et donc
pour l'instant on est très loin de cette
invasion
c'est plutôt une opportunité d'importer
des savoir faire inventer des outils et
puis de crédence loire grandiose et de
faire entrer les paysans les fermiers
roumain sur la marché avec un peu plus
de courage et avec un peu plus de chance
parce que jusqu'ici c'est vrai vu le
fait que la roumanie est entré tard en
2007 et vu cette période deux blocs de
blocage sur la libéralisation de l'achat
des terres on était quand même
marginalisée ou avant 2007 bien sûr
absent et donc ça va nous donner une
chance importante et je crois que il
faut regarder ça plutôt avec optimisme
on est au début d'une belle histoire et
non pas à la fin d'une d'une histoire de
cauchemar justement marc tarabella on
est peut-être au début effectivement
d'une belle histoire est ce qu'il ne
faut pas garder confiance dans la
capacité aussi du peuple roumain et de
ses dirigeants à créer une forme de
marché intérieur européen et à offrir en
fait cette capacité de développement à
l'agriculture roumaine sachant qu on
risque d'être en concurrence avec que ce
soit le brésil la chine l'inde en ce qui
concerne le besoin de matières premières
ce qu'on n'a pas besoin de ce grenier et
de créer ce marché intérieur agricole
avec la roumanie en troisième poste très
clairement quand on fait référence au
brésil il ya les acteurs extérieurs
comme les états unis ou desquels on
importe massivement le soja pour nourrir
notre bétail très clairement on doit
avoir une stratégie européenne d'essayer
le diminue notre dépendance à l'égard
d'autres continents notamment du
continent américain par rapport à la
production de protéines végétales et
c'est vrai que la roumanie peut il
contribuer largement mais aussi nos
voisins ont parlé de l'ukraine ya pas
tellement longtemps oui très clairement
oui mais il ya d'autres problèmes mais
bon c'est très bien mais je reste quand
même dubitatif par rapport à cette hyper
évolution qui va aller très vite et qui
va peut-être laissé sur le bord du
chemin une partie la paysannerie ou même
moi je dirais que
c'est pas la vitesse de la
transformation condac hand c'est la
lecture que fait mon collègue ben jeu
c'est justement le contraire une lenteur
parce que
on est depuis 2007 quand même un membre
de l'union européenne et les paysans
sont la catégorie sociale qui attend le
cuisse et qui disent comme monsieur dans
le reportage et qu'elle a la vitesse
n'est pas trop trop accéléré qui n'a pas
trop accéléré on attendait beaucoup de
la politique agricole mais il faut 2 aux
gens parce que nous sommes tous
européens on n'est pas des étrangers 1
par rapport à l'euro qu'on est tous
égaux et donc moi je fais un appel à ce
que les gens viennent armani la terre
est bonne marche et très bon marché
encore et donc on a des paysans qui
n'attend que s'amplifier s'investir dans
ce grand de marchés européens alors mais
comment permettre aux agriculteurs aux
mains de se constituer des parcelles on
voit que la problématique aussi c'est le
morcellement de la terre oui il commença
fin cela pourquoi parce que écoutez il
ya eu un
vrai drame au début des années 90 parce
qu'au moment de la restitution des
terres il y avait en quelque sorte le là
le drame de la du communisme deux
associations forcer à les coopératives
agricoles de production qu avait inventé
le communisme et qui était une sorte de
deux
d'associations forcé alors ils hantent
mis du temps pour s'habituer à l'idée
que l'association s'est pas simplement
la force la domination d'une autorité
d'atik mes coaches est l'expression de
la libre volonté et donc depuis quelques
années chantante injustement de
reconstituer ce tissu associatif de ce
mobile dossier voilà et pour travailler
ensemble pour échanger des expédients
c'est pour un vraiment une force de vent
devant les autorités publiques parce que
autrement la tel était mon seul et c'est
ce que je sais qu'on a restitué les
thèmes enfin c'était un acte de juger
franchement la condition sinequanone
pour réussir en fait à exister dans un
marché européen c'est une équation
simple pour conclure c'est vrai qu'elle
est permis avec un hectare en roumanie
mais imaginons qu'il grossisse qui
s'associent pour acheter du matériel et
produire mieux et plus très bien mais je
préfère 3000 hectares où vivent 100
familles sur chacune 30 hectares de 3000
hectares ou même propriétaire qui lui va
hyper s'enrichir et qui va faire vivre
dix travailleurs qui vont conduire le
tracteur dernière question messieurs
très rapidement on voit que c'est aussi
l'eldorado de l'agriculture bio la
roumanie est ce que ce sont les mêmes
standards qu'en europe de l'ouest est ce
que le bio roumain est le même que le
bio français que le bio allemand marc
tarabella oui le bio à une règle charte
éthique partout en europe doit
s'appliquer partout de la même manière
et c'est vrai qu'à côté de l'agriculture
hyper productiviste doit aussi en
roumanie coexister d'agriculture
vraiment de qualité car ils ont des
produits qualité il n'est rien de
valoriser de commercialiser partout en
europe la tomate roumaine et bien que
savoureuse que la tomate andalouse
les étrangers
jeudi des autres pays européens et non
européens qui viennent chez nous disent
ce qu'ils disent la tomate sur nos
légumes sur nos viandes ans donc c'est
vraiment du bio bio supérieur à d'autres
écoutez vous invite tous à aller manger
de la tomate roumaine et de la vigne bio
merci beaucoup monsieur d'avoir
participé à ce débat avec nous nous
c'est terminé pour cette semaine rendez
vous la semaine prochaine à strasbourg
avec ahmed tazir bonne suite de
programmes sur les chaînes
parlementaires à bientôt